chicken time
I don't eat fast food that much but if I
do I just go it all in I don't think
that I'm bougie about my chicken
sandwiches though well this looks
disgusting looks like a slice of cheese
I don't know what's up with this whole
gloss hmm I know there's why people eat
this stuff hello Bowie the bread I don't
really like the bread I like it I like
the quality a chicken is nicely spiced
it tastes like like we're chicken to us
the taste like this is the best fun by
far mmm Kardashian of buns not as good
this doesn't have any of the crispiness
at this one happens it's like plastic
toy food this one's more clumpy like
there's like pieces of chicken inside it
it's like if you cooked chicken and an
easy-bake oven thicker yeah that
actually looks like bread so that's like
here yeah this is gotta be my favorite
so far
mine kill all of them our Burger King
must've been a psychological experiment
this chicken is sweating this is
definitely maybe the thickest slice of
chicken that we have this chicken makes
me think of McDonald's and you know what
it's missing that delicious McDonald's
ketchup that first one is just crushing
and I'm upset that we started here
mm-hmm
there's a [ __ ] that peasants abstain
from shipping that's what I'm talking
about
trick fly delicious Scott damn it it's a
very social I got me home above it and
bought a pickle that makes you go like
this hey I got a pickle in my sandwich
and it's good I don't love it again this
would be better a spicy chicken by
default I have Jessup this is one of
these chav this is rubber didn't know
that 100 this good is the best one it
tastes like the [ __ ] that you get from
the frozen section Oh baby come on are
you kidding me that was that was a
chicken's butt I love this
what was the best one definitely a
design this one jack-in-the-box
great work take in the box chicklet t
know what you're doing I might
reconsider my stance on Jack and Bobby
yeah Jerry they're going there now my my
I feel like I can't chew anymore cause I
just feel like seven breads on two in my
mouth